OpenClaude 2.0 just dropped and it makes AI coding multiplayer.
The open source agent Harness calls this its biggest release ever.
933 contributors merged over 16,000 pull requests,
roughly half of everything ever merged into the project.
The headline feature, shared cloud sessions,
so your whole team works inside one agent.
Creator Peter Steinberger says local harnesses feel like relics of the past now.
One catch before you roll it out at work,
reviewers note sandboxing and command approvals ship off by default.
Lock those down first.
So would you put your whole team inside one shared agent,
or is one agent per developer the only sane way to work?
Subscribe for more AI news and tutorials every single day.